avec nous pour en parler ce soir
véronique pürro pdg des manufacturiers
et exportateurs du québec pour soir
madame pro bonsoir et sophie d'amour
rectrice de l'université laval bonsoir
madame d'amour l'ensemble et ses
filiales madame d'amour ce recul partiel
est-ce qu'il est suffisant d'abord il
faut le reconnaître vous l'appréciez
parce que c'est quand même une demande
qui était fait et puis c'est un peu dans
la bonne direction en faut saluer la
décision qui a été prise avec dirigeante
mais c'est certain que quand tu y as
l'avenir économique du québec je pense
qu'il faut continuer de travailler que
maintenir les échanges pour aller plus
loin dans cette réforme
on a besoin de tous les talents de
toutes les disciplines et bien entendu
quand on regarde certaines régions du
québec on voit bien la part qu'on les
diplômés universitaires d'un
développement économique et ce à toutes
les disciplines les gens avec toutes les
expertises et donc c'est quoi le message
selon vous qui est envoyé et quels sont
les effets qui sont à prévoir selon vous
il ya 2 il ya deux messages à dire que
on définit des catégories des expertises
qui semblait plus pertinente ou moins
pertinentes au développement économique
et nous on sait bien dans les
universités que c'est paul que on
travaille tellement hamiti et à mettre
nos étudiants ensemble pour qu'ils
puissent contribuer de façon encore plus
riche avec des idées encore plus
percutante puis des innovations plus
solide donc déjà le message de dire
qu'il ya des différences à ce niveau là
et pas est pas cohérent je pense avec la
vision de l'économie de demain
mais par ailleurs au niveau
international le message que ça envoie
et il est beaucoup et beaucoup de
distorsion loto de ce message là mais on
met en doute d'enfants là
la volonté d'accueillir des jeunes
talents de les intégrer efficacement
parce qu'il faut reconnaître que
l'intégration par l'université par la
formation par les cegep aussi c'est
certainement un des meilleurs moyens
pour permettre cette intégration au
québec puis aussi la francisation voilà
madame cruise veut vous entendre le ruhl
vise les personnes donc déjà au québec
qui auront accès aux programmes
mais le resserrement quand même des
critères d'accès à l'immigration
permanente demeure ce resserrement
alors c'est quoi les conséquences
comment vous voyez les choses en fait
nous on est très satisfaits que le
gouvernement ait reculé alors sur la
clause qui a mis en place la clause
grand-père le québec est en compétition
avec plusieurs nations à l'international
pour recruter les meilleurs talents
aller chercher des travailleurs alors on
est très satisfait de la non ce qui a eu
lieu ce matin
maintenant ceci étant dit on pense que
dans la réforme qui a été mise en place
il ya de nombreux freins de nombreux
freins qui ont été mises en place et qui
font en sorte qu'il devient plus
difficile pour les travailleurs
d'accéder l'immigration permanente et
donc pour les employeurs d'avoir accès à
la main d'oeuvre dont ils ont besoin est
ce que le milieu d'affaires demande
depuis longtemps qu'on arrive
l'immigration les travailleurs
temporaires aussi sur les besoins du
marché du travail
est ce que est ce que quelque part cette
réforme atteindre cet objectif là elle
l'attend impartis c'est à dire que
maintenant dans le cadre du programme
d'expérience québécoise il y aura
certains domaines d'études qui vont être
pris à prioriser certaines professions
aussi en lien avec les besoins du marché
du travail
donc nous on y est favorable on pense
que c'est gagnant pour le travailleur
qui va pouvoir respirer trouver un
emploi à la hauteur de ses connaissances
de ses compétences et ses gagnants pour
l'employeur qui va avoir accès de main
d'oeuvre les travailleurs qui répondent
à ses besoins
est ce que ça vient réduire ou amplifier
la rareté de main-d'oeuvre ça ne vient
pas réduire ni amplifier ce qui est
réduit ce qui va accentuer la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre c'est le fait que les
seuils n'ont pas été rehaussée alors on
demain celui d'accueil d'immigrants est
exactement
donc on vient restreindre l'accès à
l'immigration notamment parce que les
seuils n'ont pas été rehaussée alors
quand on est sur le terrain on voit les
besoins criants des employeurs des
manufacturiers
et la réforme proposée les mesures qui
ont été annoncées ne semble pas ne sont
pas bien ne répondent pas en fait aux
besoins du secteur manufacturier
québécois la réforme madame d'amour la
réforme signifie quoi pour l'université
laval en termes d'effectifs d'accueil de
recrutement notamment nous actuellement
on a un peu plus que 4000 étudiants qui
ont un visa d'études
donc c'est significatif aux 4000
étudiants étrangers étrangers qui sont
aux études sur un visa étudiant donc
aujourd'hui c'est 4000 étudiants peuvent
se prévaloir de ce programme
l'expérience québec dans sa nouvelle
mouture on réduit du tiers ce groupe et
d'utile sur les 4000 au risque vu du
ciel les les catégories aux cycles
supérieurs sont maîtrise et doctorat
sont réduites de façon significative et
enfants beaucoup d'étudiants gratuit
donc ça c'est une c'est un enjeu pour
nous un autre enjeu très local vous
savez l'économie de québec de la ville
de québec est florissante on a un taux
de chômage de 2 points 3 % tous les
talents sont recherchés tous nos
étudiants québécois internationaux sont
recherchés donc déjà là si on a réduit
l'attractivité de notre région en europe
encore plus de difficultés à répondre
aux besoins des entreprises et le
troisième élément
qui rend dans cette réforme qui nous
préoccupe beaucoup
c'est le fait qu'on ait retiré les
professeurs université de la liste des
des travailleurs qui peuvent se
prévaloir du programme
vous savez on recrute nos professeurs à
l'international on va chercher ses
experts dans différents domaines et les
attirer au québec
ben ça demande tous les outils oui des
bonnes institutions mais ça demande
aussi des modalités d assurance qu eux
et leur famille pourront s'installer
faire et que le hall un professeur pour
faire carrière
je terminais avec vous madame proulx
quelle est l'image que le québec envoie
à l'étranger
avec cette réforme sur l'immigration sur
son attractivité sur notre capacité à
attirer des travailleurs
en fait je vous dirais que lorsqu'on
vient restreindre l'accès à
l'immigration
on n'est pas ou n'est pas on n'est pas
très attractif on devient moins
attractif je pense à l'international et
je rajouterais pour répond plus
concrètement pour les entreprises qui
vivent cette pénurie la cdm est très
difficile d'aller chercher de la
villeneuve
lorsque les gens savent que lorsque nous
arriverons au québec possiblement que
les règles vont changer ou qui auront un
accès difficile lorsqu'on parle au
travail on pense aux travailleurs
étrangers qui viennent souvent de
l'amérique latine de l'asie qui vient de
travailler dans le secteur manufacturier
lorsqu'ils arrivent au québec ils
peuvent à peine ils peuvent à peine
penser avoir accès à l'immigration
permanente notamment cause des seuils
mais aussi compte tenu du niveau de
français qui est exigée dans le cadre
des mesures qui sont proposés véronique
proulx à montréal suffit d'amour à
québec merci beaucoup merci merci
bonsoir bonsoir